Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Storm of political controversy swirls around Kennedy on visit, thousands expected to greet JFK. Dallas police said Thursday night they anticipate that thousands of welcomers will jam Love Field to greet President Kennedy when his jet airliner lands there Friday morning. Ed Reynolds, president of the Dallas Retail Merchants Association, urged owners and tenants of Main Street buildings to fly the U.S. flag.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。肯尼迪访问期间，政治争议风暴四起，预计成千上万的人将迎接肯尼迪总统。达拉斯警方周四晚间表示，他们预计周五上午肯尼迪总统的喷气式客机降落时，成千上万的欢迎者将挤满爱田机场（Love Field）。达拉斯零售商协会主席埃德·雷诺兹（Ed Reynolds）敦促主街（Main Street）建筑的业主和租户悬挂美国国旗。
He said the association also arranged for overhead decorations. Former Vice President Richard Nixon, who ran against President Kennedy in 1960, joined police in urging Dallas residents to give President and Mrs. Kennedy a courteous reception. Nixon, who was in Dallas for a meeting of soft drink bottlers, said discourteous groups harm their own cause and help their opponents. One anti-Kennedy faction scattered leaflets which condemned the President for his stand on integration. President Kennedy will ride in a blue convertible. If rain is falling, a plexiglass bubble will protect him. The specially built car was flown here for use
他说，该协会还安排了高架装饰。曾在1960年与肯尼迪总统竞选的前副总统理查德·尼克松（Richard Nixon）与警方一道，敦促达拉斯居民给予总统和夫人礼貌的接待。尼克松当时正在达拉斯参加软饮料装瓶商会议，他表示，无礼的团体只会损害他们自己的事业，并帮助他们的对手。一个反肯尼迪派别散发了传单，谴责总统在种族融合问题上的立场。肯尼迪总统将乘坐一辆蓝色敞篷车。如果下雨，有机玻璃罩将保护他。这辆特制的汽车已被空运到这里，供
in the motorcade. Police said the motorcade will move slowly so that crowds can get a good view of President Kennedy and his wife. That, Dominic, was the Dallas Morning News on Friday, the 22nd of November, 1963. It is, absolutely. Never has it been read in such a remarkable accent, I have to say, Tom. There was a definite hint of Wiltshire there, I think, as much as of Dallas. I wasn't trying to be Dallas. I was trying to kind of multi-purpose, cheery 1960s US newscaster, and I think I hit the spot there. Do you think so? That's good. It's good that you think so, anyway. Well, we're talking of hitting the spot. Well, there's a lot of ironers there, aren't there? There's a lot of ironers in that article. The fly on the US flag,
车队使用。警方表示，车队将缓慢行驶，以便人群能清楚地看到肯尼迪总统和他的妻子。多米尼克，那是1963年11月22日星期五的《达拉斯晨报》。确实如此。汤姆，我不得不说，这段文字读起来有着非凡的口音。我想，其中既有威尔特郡（Wiltshire）的韵味，也有达拉斯的味道。我并不是在刻意模仿达拉斯口音。我试图扮演一个多功能的、欢快的20世纪60年代美国新闻播音员，我想我做到了。你觉得呢？那很好。不管怎样，你这么认为很好。好吧，我们谈到了重点。嗯，那篇文章里有很多讽刺意味，不是吗？那篇文章里有很多讽刺。悬挂美国国旗，
the presence of Richard Nixon, who has just been in Dallas for a meeting of soft drink bottlers. Yeah. Urging a courteous reception. Yeah. And the police saying the motorcade will move slowly so the crowd can get a good view of President Kennedy and his wife. And kind of the grim, macabre irony of that is one that no one needs explaining because the events of Friday,
理查德·尼克松的出席，他刚在达拉斯参加了一个软饮料装瓶商会议。是的。敦促给予礼貌的接待。是的。还有警方说车队将缓慢行驶，以便人群能清楚地看到肯尼迪总统和他的妻子。而其中那种冷酷、恐怖的讽刺，不需要任何人解释，因为周五发生的事件，
the 22nd of November, 1963 are so iconic that pretty much everyone knows about it. Yes. And I have to say, Dominic, you recommended that I read Parkland by Vincent Bugliosi, which is one of the most gripping history books that I've ever read.
1963年11月22日，是如此具有标志性，以至于几乎每个人都知道。是的。多米尼克，我不得不说，你推荐我读文森特·布格里奥西（Vincent Bugliosi）的《帕克兰》（Parkland），这是我读过的最引人入胜的历史书之一。
Twinkie. Wow. It's a kind of blow by blow, almost minute by minute account of everything that happens on the day of Kennedy's assassination and the days that follow. And what I found when I was reading it, it's a bit like kind of reading Hamlet for the first time, where you're aware of all the quotations, but you don't quite know how they fit in. And likewise, I had a sense of grassy knolls and Jack Ruby and book dispensaries and things like that. But you read it and you thread it all together and you realize that this is one of the great primal narratives now of history. It is absolutely modern history. Certainly it's become a foundational myth for modern America, the moment of lost innocence, hasn't it? And you mentioned that Bugliosi book. So I reviewed that for the Daily Telegraph, I think about 15 years ago. And it had a different title then, it was
天哪。哇。这是一份关于肯尼迪遇刺当天及随后几天所发生一切的逐点、几乎是逐分钟的记录。我在阅读时发现，这有点像第一次读《哈姆雷特》，你熟悉所有的引语，但并不完全了解它们是如何衔接在一起的。同样，我对草丘（grassy knolls）、杰克·鲁比（Jack Ruby）、图书仓库（book dispensaries）之类的事情也有所耳闻。但当你读完并把它们串联起来时，你会意识到这已成为当今历史上最伟大的原始叙事之一。这绝对是现代历史。当然，它已成为现代美国的奠基神话，一个失去纯真的时刻，不是吗？你提到了布格里奥西的那本书。我想大约15年前，我为《每日电讯报》写过书评。那时它的书名不同，
called Four Days in November. And it has a really interesting history because actually it's quite a long book isn't it yeah but it is merely a fragment yeah of a much longer book called proclaiming history which is this enormous survey not just of the events of the day but a biography of lee harvey oswald and an absolutely forensic investigation of all the conspiracy theories surrounding kenn's assassination. So it's an extraordinary, extraordinary book. And Bugliosi himself is a remarkable man because he was the prosecutor of Charles Manson, the Manson murders in the late 1960s. Helter Skelter. Helter Skelter was his book about the case. And Dominic, can I just ask, I am not in any way an expert in this at all, as
叫《十一月的四天》（Four Days in November）。它有一段非常有趣的历史，因为实际上它是一本很长的书，对吧？是的，但这仅仅是一本更长著作《宣告历史》（Reclaiming History）的片段，那是一项巨大的调查，不仅涵盖了当天的事件，还包括李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德（Lee Harvey Oswald）的传记，以及对围绕肯尼迪遇刺的所有阴谋论的绝对法医式调查。所以这是一本非常、非常了不起的书。布格里奥西本人也是一个了不起的人，因为他是20世纪60年代末查尔斯·曼森（Charles Manson）曼森谋杀案的检察官。《赫尔特·斯凯尔特》（Helter Skelter）就是他关于该案的书。多米尼克，我能问一下吗？我完全不是这方面的专家，正如
listeners will already have gauged. To what extent does Bug the Ozy's book hold up? Is it widely recognized as authoritative or does it have lots of critics still to this day? First of all, if you look on Amazon, you'll find loads of disobliging reviews of it. It's very unpopular with people in what you might call the conspiracy community or people who are sympathetic to the conspiracy theoriesists. So lots of people will say he goes too far in trying to sort of sow the conspiracy theorists' fields with salt. The other thing, I mean, we were talking about this, weren't we, off air in the last few days. The Kennedy assassination is not a subject that academics write about, that academic scholars write about. So there's very little, as it were, scholarly literature on the Kennedy assassination. Because it's like Atlantis or aliens.
听众们已经察觉到的那样。布格里奥西的书在多大程度上站得住脚？它被广泛认为是权威的吗？还是至今仍有许多批评者？首先，如果你在亚马逊上查看，会发现大量对其不满的评论。它在所谓的阴谋论圈子或同情阴谋论者的人群中非常不受欢迎。所以很多人会说，他在试图将阴谋论者的领域“撒盐”方面走得太远了。另一件事，我的意思是，我们过去几天在节目外讨论过这个问题，不是吗？肯尼迪遇刺案并不是学术界研究的主题，学术学者们并不研究它。因此，关于肯尼迪遇刺案的学术文献非常少。因为它就像亚特兰蒂斯或外星人一样。
Exactly. It is seen as a sort of Graham Hancock shaped hole into which you will fall and you'll never climb out again. And you'll find yourself in this weird sort of hall of mirrors. And it doesn't really play a part in any kind of scholarly conversations about 20th century America. I think because people are frightened of it because they think it's the stuff of UFOs and as you say, ancient Atlantis and the Yeti and all that business. And yet, I mean, it is very, very historically significant, isn't it? As a foundational episode in modern America, as you said, but also as an expression of powerful themes in American history. Absolutely. Absolutely. All the anxieties about the Kennedy assassination, the anxieties about
正是如此。它被视为一个格雷厄姆·汉考克（Graham Hancock）式的黑洞，一旦掉进去就永远爬不出来。你会发现自己置身于这种奇怪的镜厅之中。它在任何关于20世纪美国的学术对话中都没有真正发挥作用。我想是因为人们害怕它，因为他们认为这是UFO、正如你所说的古代亚特兰蒂斯、雪人等等之类的事情。然而，我的意思是，它在历史上确实非常、非常重要，不是吗？正如你所说，它是现代美国的奠基事件，也是美国历史上强大主题的表达。绝对是。绝对是。所有关于肯尼迪遇刺案的焦虑，关于
an overreaching government, about corrupt conspirators, about an establishment that rigged things to suit themselves, all of those kinds of things. But also, of course, it opens up windows into the tumult about civil rights in the early 1960s. About Vietnam. Yeah, the rise of the new conservatism in opposition to the sort of top-down establishment liberalism. Vietnam, as you say, Cold War, Cuba, all of these kinds of things. So, Dominic, all the themes essentially that we were kind of touching on in our previous episode where we looked at the achievements or non-achievements of Kennedy's presidency. But you brought us to Texas in November 1963.
政府权力过大、腐败的阴谋家、操纵一切以满足自身利益的建制派的焦虑，所有这些事情。但当然，它也打开了了解20世纪60年代初民权运动动荡的窗口。关于越南。是的，新保守主义的兴起，以对抗那种自上而下的建制派自由主义。越南，正如你所说，冷战，古巴，所有这些事情。所以，多米尼克，基本上就是我们在上一集讨论肯尼迪总统任期的成就或非成就时所触及的所有主题。但你把我们带到了1963年11月的德克萨斯州。
And so perhaps now we should dive in deep and look at the events of his trip to Texas. Because you said that Parkland was originally called Four Days in November. And that was the name of a film that was released in 1964. It was nominated for an Oscar as Best Documentary, and I watched that last night. I hadn't realized that actually Kennedy had gone to Florida beforehand. Yes, that's right. He was making a general kind of southern trip. To shore up his base.
所以也许现在我们应该深入探讨他德克萨斯之行的事件。因为你说《帕克兰》最初叫《十一月的四天》。那是1964年上映的一部电影的名字。它获得了奥斯卡最佳纪录片提名，我昨晚看了。我之前没意识到肯尼迪在那之前还去了佛罗里达。是的，没错。他当时正在进行一次普遍的南方之行。为了巩固他的基本盘。
Right. As we said last time, if you listened to our podcast last week about Kennedy's early life and then his road to the presidency and his presidency, Kennedy in November 1963 is looking forward to the election a year later. He has the best approval ratings that anyone has ever had. On the other hand, as with all democratic presidents, his re-election depends upon him preserving a coalition of kind of northern cities and industrial states and the, up to this point, solidly democratic South. But his support for civil rights in the summer of 1963 has imperiled his coalition in the South. So it makes sense for him to do this little Southern tour a year out from the election to show his face, do all the airport photo calls, taking Jackie with him will bring greater publicity because he knows how popular she is and how much people
对。正如我们上次所说，如果你听了我们上周关于肯尼迪早年生活、通往总统之路以及他总统任期的播客，1963年11月的肯尼迪正期待着一年后的选举。他拥有有史以来最好的支持率。另一方面，正如所有民主党总统一样，他的连任取决于他能否维持一个由北方城市、工业州以及到目前为止稳固的民主党南方组成的联盟。但他在1963年夏天对民权运动的支持，已经危及了他在南方的联盟。所以，在选举前一年进行这次小型的南方巡回访问，露露面，参加所有的机场拍照活动，带上杰基，因为他知道她有多受欢迎，人们有多么
are excited to see her. And this is her first trip with him since 1960 on a kind of trip like this. Exactly. But also, crucially, it's her first trip since the tragic loss of their baby son, Patrick, who had died, I think, two days after being born in August. And this had been a devastating moment for both of them. They have two children already, John Jr. and Caroline. She had gone into a deep depression, but people said it had kind of brought them closer together. So they are making the trip together. It is a kind of special moment for them.
兴奋地见到她，这对他来说是有意义的。这是她自1960年以来第一次和他一起进行这样的旅行。正是如此。但至关重要的是，这也是她自他们的小儿子帕特里克（Patrick）不幸夭折以来的第一次旅行，我想他在8月出生两天后就去世了。这对他们两人来说都是一个毁灭性的时刻。他们已经有两个孩子，小约翰（John Jr.）和卡罗琳（Caroline）。她曾陷入深深的抑郁，但人们说这反而让他们更加亲密了。所以他们一起参加这次旅行。这对他们来说是一个特殊的时刻。
So as you say, Tom, they've been in Florida on Thursday, the 21st of November. Kennedy, of course, doesn't know it, but he has a day to live. They fly into Texas. They go to San Antonio. They meet up with Vice President Johnson and his wife, Lady Bird Johnson. They go to Houston for a dinner. And then very late at night, so about 11 o'clock, they arrive in Fort Worth, which is Dallas. It's kind of sister city there. They're effectively one metropolis. They get into the hotel very late.
所以正如你所说，汤姆，他们11月21日星期四在佛罗里达。肯尼迪当然不知道，但他只剩下一天的生命了。他们飞往德克萨斯。他们去了圣安东尼奥。他们与副总统约翰逊（Johnson）和他的妻子伯德夫人（Lady Bird Johnson）会合。他们去休斯顿参加了一场晚宴。然后很晚，大约11点，他们抵达了沃斯堡（Fort Worth），也就是达拉斯。那是那里的姐妹城市。他们实际上是一个大都市。他们很晚才入住酒店。
It's going to be a busy day the next day, so they go straight to bed. And JFK doesn't have the best suite, does he, that goes to LBJ? Because the Secret Service are worried it's not secure enough. That's right. That's absolutely right. He has a decent suite. It's in the Texas Hotel in Fort Worth. He doesn't sleep in the same bedroom as Jackie. That's absolutely right. He has a decent suite. He's in the Texas hotel in Fort Worth. He doesn't sleep in the same bedroom as Jackie. That's very common. He's obviously going to be
第二天会很忙，所以他们直接去睡觉了。肯尼迪住的不是最好的套房，对吧？那是留给LBJ的。因为特勤局担心那里的安保不够严密。没错。绝对没错。他住的套房还不错。它在沃斯堡的德克萨斯酒店（Texas Hotel）。他没有和杰基睡在同一个卧室。绝对没错。他住的套房还不错。他在沃斯堡的德克萨斯酒店。他没有和杰基睡在同一个卧室。这很常见。他显然会
working late often. She won't want to go to bed earlier. That's sort of fairly standard. And they've got a very busy day lined up. The plan for Friday the 22nd in November is there will be a breakfast event in Fort Worth at the hotel, and they'll have local business leaders from Fort Worth. They will then fly to Dallas. We'll talk about the flight in a second, but they'll fly to Dallas. He will go through the streets of Dallas in a motorcade, which you talked about in that Dallas Morning News clipping. He will speak to Dallas business leaders at the Trademarks, just outside Dallas's downtown to the south. And then he will go on to Austin, Texas for an evening fundraiser. And then he's going will go on to austin texas for an evening
经常工作到很晚。她不会想早睡。这算是相当标准的。他们安排了非常忙碌的一天。11月22日星期五的计划是，在沃斯堡的酒店举行早餐会，他们将接待沃斯堡当地的商业领袖。然后他们将飞往达拉斯。我们稍后再谈这次飞行，但他们会飞往达拉斯。他将乘坐车队穿过达拉斯的街道，也就是你在《达拉斯晨报》剪报中提到的那样。他将在达拉斯市中心南部的贸易中心（Trade Mart）向达拉斯商业领袖发表演讲。然后他将前往德克萨斯州奥斯汀参加晚上的筹款活动。然后他将前往奥斯汀参加晚上的
fundraiser and then he's going to go on to lbj's ranch isn't he yes he's going to rest at lbj's ranch and then on saturday the next day he will go back to washington and the big thing they're looking forward to is their son john jr's third birthday on monday it's very important to them they're back for john jr's birthday oh Oh, dear. The shadows of tragedy are awful. Well, there's a human story here. There are multiple human stories that are so often forgotten amid the swirl of conspiracy, paranoia and stuff. Right. So let's go on to Friday and let's take this kind of-
筹款活动，然后他将前往LBJ的牧场，不是吗？是的，他要去LBJ的牧场休息，然后周六第二天他将回到华盛顿。他们最期待的大事是周一小约翰的三岁生日。这对他们来说非常重要。他们会赶回来参加小约翰的生日。哦，天哪。悲剧的阴影真是太可怕了。好吧，这里有一个人类的故事。在阴谋、偏执和各种事情的漩涡中，有多个经常被遗忘的人类故事。好吧，让我们进入周五，让我们采取这种——
Play by blow. Like detectives piling up the evidence, let's pile up the evidence. Kennedy awakes at about 7.30 in the morning. As you said, Tom, he's not in the best suite. He's on the eighth floor. He has a black man servant called George Thomas who often goes in to wake him. And George Thomas puts out his suit and whatnot. They don't get much peace. You don't get much sort of solitude if you're the president of the United States because they've got all this huge entourage and they've got all this colossal amount of equipment that they take with them. It's a phone, isn't there? So he can reach anywhere in the world at any time. He's meant to be never more than five minutes away from this crucial network that will plug
逐点分析。就像侦探堆积证据一样，让我们堆积证据。肯尼迪大约在早上7点30分醒来。正如你所说，汤姆，他住的不是最好的套房。他在八楼。他有一个叫乔治·托马斯（George Thomas）的黑人男仆，经常进去叫醒他。乔治·托马斯会为他准备好西装之类的东西。他们得不到多少安宁。如果你是美国总统，你就得不到多少独处时间，因为他们有庞大的随从队伍，还有他们随身携带的巨量设备。那是一部电话，不是吗？所以他可以随时联系世界上的任何地方。他被要求距离这个关键网络永远不超过五分钟，这个网络将把他接入
him into the White House switchboard and mean that he can reach. If he wanted to call you, Tom, he could do it. He could do it. Exactly. So he gets up. Jackie is still asleep. The description of him getting up is actually a fascinating insight into the health problems that we talked about last week. So he has been sleeping on a sort of board that he has, a special bed board, which goes with him wherever he goes for his back, which is destroyed. He puts on this back brace, this sort of stiff corset type thing. This will be important, won't it yeah when
白宫总机，意味着他可以联系。如果他想给你打电话，汤姆，他就能做到。他能做到。正是如此。所以他起床了。杰基还在睡觉。关于他起床的描述实际上是对我们上周讨论的健康问题的一个迷人洞察。他一直睡在一块他随身携带的特殊床板上，为了他的背部，他的背部已经毁了。他穿上这个背部支架，那种僵硬的紧身胸衣。这很重要，不是吗？当
the events happen the role of that and dominic again just to name check the four days in november the documentary i saw there is a sequence of him getting into his car in florida and oh the look of pain on his face as he sits down really really vivid yeah and also kind of throw away comment from a journalist a reporter saying about, you know, you could see his tan from five miles away. And he's got that tan, hasn't he, principally to cover up kind of the marks of pain and illness that he's got on his face. That's right. He's a good example of somebody who, because he's in such horrendous health, actually almost overcompensates by presenting a portrait of kind of glowing good health at all
事件发生时，那个东西的作用。多米尼克，再次提一下我看的纪录片《十一月的四天》，里面有一个他坐进佛罗里达车里的镜头，哦，他坐下时脸上的痛苦表情，真的非常生动。还有一位记者随口说的一句话，说你可以从五英里外看到他的晒黑肤色。他有那种晒黑的肤色，不是吗？主要是为了掩盖他脸上那种痛苦和疾病的痕迹。没错。他是一个很好的例子，因为他健康状况极其糟糕，实际上几乎通过表现出一种容光焕发的健康形象来过度补偿。
times. But the tan also helps him to disguise the fact that he's taking the cocktail of drugs. He has Addison's disease. He has suffered with fever ever since World War II. So the tan helps to cover up the fact that he would otherwise look very sallow and kind of yellow. So yes, he goes through this great operation of getting ready. It's now about eight o'clock and there are 5,000 people downstairs in the parking lot of the hotel and many of them have been waiting for three hours or so to see him. So actually the granular detail gives you a sense of the demands on any public figure in the early 1960s. And especially a president. Yeah. He is given his news briefing for the day. There's very
但晒黑也帮助他掩盖了他在服用鸡尾酒药物的事实。他患有阿狄森氏病（Addison's disease）。自二战以来，他一直饱受发烧之苦。所以晒黑有助于掩盖他本来会显得非常蜡黄和苍白的事实。所以是的，他经历了这一整套准备工作。现在大约是八点钟，酒店停车场楼下有5000人，他们中的许多人已经等了三个小时左右来见他。所以实际上，这些颗粒状的细节让你感受到了20世纪60年代初对任何公众人物的要求。尤其是总统。是的。他收到了当天的简报。有非常
little news. Actually, the fact that one of the leading items in the news briefing is a Labour Party victory in the Dundee West by-election in Britain, Tom. Labour winning by-elections in Scotland, whatever next. Yes. But the big news in the press is twofold. First of all, as we talked about last time, there was terrible faction fighting within the Texas Democratic Party. He won Texas by, what, 46,000 votes or something in 1960. So not many. He needs the Texas Democratic Party to be united. The feud between Governor Connolly and Senator Yarbrough, so on the relatively conservative, relatively liberal wings of the party, respectively, that's a problem and he has to fix it. That's part of what this trip to Dallas is all about. But the other big thing
少的新闻。实际上，新闻简报中的头条之一是英国邓迪西选区（Dundee West）补选中工党的胜利，汤姆。工党在苏格兰赢得补选，接下来会发生什么。是的。但媒体的大新闻有两点。首先，正如我们上次讨论的那样，德克萨斯民主党内部存在可怕的派系斗争。他在1960年以46000票左右的优势赢得了德克萨斯州。所以没多大优势。他需要德克萨斯民主党团结一致。州长康纳利（Connally）和参议员亚伯勒（Yarborough）之间的不和，分别处于党内相对保守和相对自由的派系，这是一个问题，他必须解决它。这就是这次达拉斯之行的部分目的。但另一件大事
is about his reception. Now, you mentioned Nixon saying he hoped that Kennedy would get a courteous reception. Dallas, in particular, has a reputation as being a difficult place to visit. So Lyndon Johnson, who is from Texas, had been spat at during the 1960 presidential campaign. More pertinently, Kennedy's predecessor as the kind of democratic standard bearer, Adlai Stevenson, who's now his ambassador to the United Nations, he had actually been hit with a placard and spat at less than a month earlier. And the Secret Service, I gather, had recorded 34 threats on the president's life from Texas between 1961 to 62. So Kennedy kind of knows what he says, doesn't he? Oh, we're heading into nut country today. He does indeed. So Dallas has this reputation as a hotbed of conservatism. It's a very business-friendly town. It's a town with a lot of people who are suspicious of the federal government. Obviously, civil rights has ignited a power keg among a lot of white Southerners.
是关于他的接待。现在，你提到了尼克松说他希望肯尼迪能得到礼貌的接待。达拉斯尤其以难以访问而闻名。所以来自德克萨斯的林登·约翰逊（Lyndon Johnson）在1960年总统竞选期间曾被人吐过口水。更贴切地说，肯尼迪作为民主党旗手的继任者，现任联合国大使的阿德莱·史蒂文森（Adlai Stevenson），在不到一个月前曾被人用标语牌击中并吐过口水。据我所知，特勤局记录了1961年至1962年间来自德克萨斯的34起针对总统生命的威胁。所以肯尼迪有点知道他在说什么，不是吗？哦，我们今天正前往疯子之国。他确实知道。所以达拉斯有这种作为保守主义温床的声誉。这是一个非常商业友好的城市。这是一个有很多对联邦政府持怀疑态度的人的城市。显然，民权运动在许多白人南方人中点燃了火药桶。
There have been leaflets out on the streets with Kennedy's face on saying, wanted for treason, all of this kind of thing. Now, the interesting thing is that how much are we focusing on these things because they're unusual, or how much are we focusing on them because we know Kennedy is going to be assassinated? In the 1950s and 1960s, it was very common to see leaflets and pamphlets and things like that making strident, wild political claims. So this is the heyday of the far-right John Birch Society. Obviously, the Ku Klux Klan is still kind of going strong in parts of the South. There are inflamed passions and have been for considerable time. I mean, it's not that long since McCarthyism. So there are lots of people, I mean, not a majority, of course, by any means, but there are people who will say Kennedy is a communist.
街头出现了印有肯尼迪头像的传单，上面写着“因叛国罪被通缉”，诸如此类的事情。现在，有趣的是，我们关注这些事情是因为它们不寻常，还是因为我们知道肯尼迪将被暗杀？在20世纪50年代和60年代，看到传单、小册子之类做出尖锐、疯狂的政治主张是非常普遍的。所以这是极右翼约翰·伯奇协会（John Birch Society）的全盛时期。显然，三K党在南方部分地区仍然很活跃。激情被点燃了，而且已经持续了相当长一段时间。我的意思是，麦卡锡主义过去没多久。所以有很多人，我的意思是，当然绝不是大多数，但确实有人会说肯尼迪是共产主义者。
You know, there are people who think Eisenhower was a communist. So the fact that there are leaflets and the fact that there are people who are possibly going to heckle him, that's not something he's unused to. You know, that is part of the territory in early 60s America.
你知道，有些人认为艾森豪威尔是共产主义者。所以有传单和可能要对他进行质问的人，这对他来说并不陌生。你知道，这是60年代初美国的一部分。
But there does seem to have been, and maybe this is retrospective, but I don't think so, there does seem to have been a particular jumpiness around this trip. The plan is what? That he's going to drive nine and a half miles in a motorcade past very high rise buildings. I mean, people in the security service are twitchy about this, right? They are. Yeah, of course they are. They know that Kennedy, he likes to put himself into the crowds. He likes to stop and greet people. All of that glad-handing is part of his style. And it's the security service's job to try and intercept these things. Somebody had tried to shoot Roosevelt in the 1930s. Every year there are death threats against American presidents. So of course they are anxious. I guess they're confident that they
但似乎确实存在，也许这是回顾性的，但我认为不是，似乎确实围绕这次旅行有一种特别的紧张感。计划是什么？他要乘坐车队经过高层建筑行驶九英里半。我的意思是，安全部门的人对此很紧张，对吧？他们是。是的，当然。他们知道肯尼迪喜欢让自己置身于人群中。他喜欢停下来问候人们。所有这些握手寒暄都是他风格的一部分。而安全部门的工作就是试图拦截这些事情。有人曾在20世纪30年代试图枪杀罗斯福。每年都有针对美国总统的死亡威胁。所以他们当然很焦虑。我想他们很自信他们
can handle it. Otherwise they wouldn't be doing the motorcade at all. But that morning's all going very well, isn't it? The breakfast meeting in the Grand Ballroom goes tremendously. Kennedy does his bants. Jackie turns up a bit late because she's been titivating and she turns up in her pink Chanel suit. And Kennedy kind of jokes that in Paris he'd been introduced as the guy who accompanies Mrs. Kennedy. And it's much the same thing in texas and there's much horse play with a stetson hat there is but he doesn't put it on he doesn't want to put it on yes and then he gets given a pair of cowboy boots to guard against the rattlesnakes at lbj's ranch so it's all seems to be going tremendously well it does go well this goes very well and as you say jackie i mean how can she
能处理好。否则他们根本就不会安排车队。但那天早上一切都很顺利，不是吗？大宴会厅的早餐会非常成功。肯尼迪讲了他的笑话。杰基因为打扮迟到了，她穿着那套粉红色的香奈儿套装出现了。肯尼迪开玩笑说，在巴黎他被介绍为“陪同肯尼迪夫人的人”。在德克萨斯也是一样，那里有很多关于牛仔帽的玩笑。确实有，但他没有戴上，他不想戴。是的，然后他被赠送了一双牛仔靴，以防范LBJ牧场上的响尾蛇，所以一切似乎都进行得非常顺利。确实进行得很顺利，这进行得非常好。正如你所说，杰基，我的意思是她怎么
possibly know that when she puts on that outfit that morning which is this very elegant pink chanel suit with a pillbox hat that that is the outfit with which she'll be forever associated that ends up being splattered with her husband's blood anyway they do the fort worth event that's all great they go back upstairs they've got a few moments before they have to go so they go back up to the suite and it's actually when he's in the suite that his aide, Ken O'Donnell, shows him the Dallas Morning News. And the Dallas Morning News that morning is carrying a full-page advertisement with a funereal kind of black border that says, Welcome, Mr. Kennedy, to Dallas. Now, this ad is going to be very important later on for Jack Ruby, so listeners should kind of make a note of this.
可能知道，当她那天早上穿上那套衣服时，那套非常优雅的粉红色香奈儿套装配药盒帽，那将是她永远与之联系在一起的服装，最终会被她丈夫的血溅满。无论如何，他们完成了沃斯堡的活动，那很棒，他们回到楼上，在必须出发前还有一点时间，所以他们回到套房。实际上，当他在套房里时，他的助手肯·奥唐奈（Ken O'Donnell）给他看了《达拉斯晨报》。那天早上的《达拉斯晨报》刊登了一则带有葬礼式黑色边框的全页广告，上面写着：“欢迎肯尼迪先生来到达拉斯”。现在，这则广告后来对杰克·鲁比非常重要，所以听众应该记下这一点。
The ad says that it's been placed by something called the American Fact-Finding Committee, chaired by one Bernard Weissman. And it has 12 questions for Kennedy. And the 12 questions are basically, why are you supporting communist policies? Why do the communists rejoice in all your achievements? Why have you been using the Central Intelligence Agency to assassinate and eliminate our anti-communist allies. So this, of course, is a reference to something we talked about last week, Tom, which is the coup in South Vietnam against President Diem. Diem had been killed.
广告说它是由一个叫“美国事实调查委员会”（American Fact-Finding Committee）的组织投放的，由伯纳德·韦斯曼（Bernard Weissman）担任主席。它对肯尼迪提出了12个问题。这12个问题基本上是：你为什么要支持共产主义政策？为什么共产主义者为你所有的成就感到高兴？你为什么要利用中央情报局来暗杀和清除我们的反共盟友。所以这当然是指我们上周讨论过的事情，汤姆，也就是针对南越总统吴廷琰（Diem）的政变。吴廷琰被杀了。
The CIA knew about it, and Kennedy was very conflicted about it. And Kennedy sees this advertisement, and it's clear that it makes him anxious. He's cross about it. And so this point that he says to O'Donnell and the other people in the room, he sort of just says it idly. He looks out the window and says, it wouldn't be very difficult
中央情报局知道这件事，肯尼迪对此非常矛盾。肯尼迪看到了这则广告，很明显这让他感到焦虑。他对此很生气。所以他向奥唐奈和房间里的其他人说的那一点，他只是随口说的。他看着窗外说，射杀美国总统
to shoot the president of the United States. You just have to be in a high building with a high-powered rifle, telescopic sight, and there's nothing anybody could do about it. Well, that is a chilling note, I think, on which to finish the first half. And when we come back, we will follow JFK and Jackie Kennedy on the motorcade into Dallas. Entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
并不困难。你只需要在一栋高楼里，拿着一支高功率步枪，配上望远镜瞄准镜，任何人对此都无能为力。好吧，我认为这是一个令人不寒而栗的结尾，用来结束上半场。当我们回来时，我们将跟随肯尼迪和杰基·肯尼迪乘坐车队进入达拉斯。娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐界的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in Fort Worth, Dominic, but we are about to leave with the Kennedys for Lovefield, Dallas. And this is quite odd, isn't it? Because actually it's a 30 minute drive. But Kennedy wants to convey the sense of arriving in Dallas, Air Force One, his emergence from the plane, Jackie's emergence, it will be on all the news. And so that's what they do. It's true.
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。多米尼克，我们现在在沃斯堡，但我们即将和肯尼迪夫妇一起前往达拉斯爱田机场。这很奇怪，不是吗？因为实际上开车只需要30分钟。但肯尼迪想要传达一种抵达达拉斯的感觉，空军一号，他从飞机上走出来，杰基走出来，这将在所有新闻中播出。所以这就是他们所做的。这是真的。
It's a 13-minute flight from Fort Worth to Dallas. I've been to both Fort Worth and Dallas, Tom, and they're very close. I mean, they're effectively the same city. I know that will offend people in Fort Worth, but it's bonkers to fly between them. But of course, as you say, if it's all about the campaign, it's all about television. Kennedy is a master of television. And the point is to have the grand entrance at the airport. So they get onto Air Force One at 11.25. At 11.40, they land at Lovefield, which is north of downtown Dallas. And everything is looking good. It's a beautiful day, beautiful autumn day, because it had been rainy before, hadn't it? And that's cleared up. Hence the talk of the
从沃斯堡到达拉斯只有13分钟的飞行。汤姆，我去过沃斯堡和达拉斯，它们非常近。我的意思是，它们实际上是同一个城市。我知道这会冒犯沃斯堡的人，但在这两个城市之间飞行简直是疯了。但当然，正如你所说，如果这一切都是为了竞选，这一切都是为了电视。肯尼迪是电视大师。重点是在机场进行盛大的入场。所以他们在11点25分登上空军一号。11点40分，他们降落在达拉斯北部的爱田机场。一切看起来都不错。这是一个美好的一天，美丽的秋日，因为之前一直在下雨，不是吗？而雨已经停了。因此才有了关于
plexiglass bubble that would have gone on his car had it continued to rain. So they're delighted. They're delighted that the weather is so good. Kennedy says to Ken O'Donnell, his aide, oh, this is great. This trip is going to be terrific. Looks like everything in Texas is actually going to be really good for us. And they come down the steps. There is a big crowd there again, 2,000 people or so, and both Jack Kennedy and Jackie, they kind of work the line a little bit. Now, there are some signs of hostility in the crowd. There are some placards that say traitor, or they proclaim their support for Barry Goldwater, the likely Republican nominee in 1964, or they say Yankee go home or
如果继续下雨，他车上会安装的有机玻璃罩的讨论。所以他们很高兴。他们很高兴天气这么好。肯尼迪对他的助手肯·奥唐奈说，哦，这太棒了。这次旅行会非常精彩。看起来德克萨斯的一切实际上对我们来说都会非常好。他们走下台阶。那里又有一大群人，大约2000人，杰基·肯尼迪和肯尼迪都稍微走近人群互动了一下。现在，人群中确实有一些敌意的迹象。有一些标语牌写着“叛徒”，或者宣称他们支持巴里·戈德华特（Barry Goldwater），即1964年可能的共和党提名人，或者他们说“扬基回家”或
anything like this, but nothing on the scale that they had feared so that's actually looking pretty good because you would expect this anyway at these kinds of events yeah so within about 15 minutes about 11 55 they're all off the planes the whole entourage and they're getting into the motorcade and dominic just to mention one thing yeah jackie has been given a bouquet of red roses she hasn't Which she holds and she takes with her into the car. That's right. Yes. Now, this motorcade that has been so controversial and has made for so many difficult conversations
诸如此类的话，但规模没有他们担心的那么大，所以这实际上看起来相当不错，因为你在这种活动中本来就会预料到这些。是的，所以在大约15分钟内，大约11点55分，他们都下了飞机，整个随从队伍，他们正在进入车队。多米尼克，提一件事，是的，杰基收到了一束红玫瑰，她没有——她拿着它，带着它上了车。没错。是的。现在，这个一直备受争议并引发了许多困难对话的车队，
because the three key people in the Texas Democratic Party, who are the Vice President Lyndon Johnson, the Governor of Texas, John Connolly, and Senator Ralph Yarborough have been squabbling like children, disinviting each other from dinners, refusing to sit next to each other in the cars. I mean, this is the... And Kennedy has had a real go at Yarborough that morning and said, I'm going to travel with Governor Connolly in the first car. I don't care if you and Lyndon are not on speaking terms.
因为德克萨斯民主党的三位关键人物，即副总统林登·约翰逊、德克萨斯州州长约翰·康纳利和参议员拉尔夫·亚伯勒（Ralph Yarborough），像孩子一样争吵，互相取消晚宴邀请，拒绝在车里坐在一起。我的意思是，这是……肯尼迪那天早上确实对亚伯勒发了火，说：“我将和康纳利州长坐在第一辆车里。我不在乎你和林登是否在说话。”
You will go in that car together. And so finally, they've got that all sorted out. It's a huge motorcade because there's so much security. Lots of police cars, policemen on motorbikes. Kennedy will go in the third car. So there are police cars, Secret Service and whatnot that will go first. Kennedy will go in car number three, which is a Lincoln Continental, specially armor plated and customized. And he and Jacqueline will ride in that car with John Connolly, the governor of Texas, and Nellie Connolly, the governor's wife. And Connolly and his wife are in the front, right? And Kennedy and Jackie are in the back. And there's a kind of raised seat. Is that right? That Kennedy can be kind of lifted up so that he's more the center of attention.
“你们必须一起坐那辆车。”所以最终，他们解决了所有问题。这是一个巨大的车队，因为有太多的安保。大量的警车，骑摩托车的警察。肯尼迪将坐在第三辆车里。所以会有警车、特勤局之类的车先走。肯尼迪将坐在三号车里，那是一辆林肯大陆（Lincoln Continental），经过特别装甲加固和定制。他和杰奎琳将与德克萨斯州州长约翰·康纳利和州长夫人内莉·康纳利（Nellie Connolly）一起乘坐那辆车。康纳利和他的妻子坐在前面，对吧？肯尼迪和杰基坐在后面。有一个升高的座位。是这样吗？肯尼迪可以被抬高，这样他更能成为关注的中心。
So there are two Secret Service men right at the front, including the driver, Bill Greer. Then you're absolutely right, Tom. There is what's called jump seats. So they are the seats that are kind of put down so that Nellie and John Connolly can sit on them. And they are slightly lower than the Kennedyys seats and slightly more kind of positioned inside the car yeah so that the kennedys will get much more attention they'll be just a tiny bit higher they'll get their sort of focus of attention caesar on top of the chariot precisely so they're not going to have the bubble top hood behind them is a secret service car behind the
所以前面有两名特勤局人员，包括司机比尔·格里尔（Bill Greer）。然后你是绝对正确的，汤姆。有所谓的跳板座（jump seats）。所以这些座位是放下来的，这样内莉和约翰·康纳利可以坐在上面。它们比肯尼迪的座位稍微低一点，位置也稍微靠车内一点，是的，这样肯尼迪夫妇会得到更多的关注，他们会稍微高一点，他们会成为关注的焦点，就像凯撒站在战车上一样。正是如此，所以他们不会有防雨罩。他们后面是特勤局的车，在
secret service car is the car containing lyndon johnson and his wife lady bird and senator yarborough and then behind them is this colossal host of entourage cars and bikes and also the press sort of cars containing the press and they're all going to sweep through dallas the nine and a half miles to the trade mart and i think it's really important to give people a sense at this point of the key bit of the route they're going to come through downtown dallas south down main street so that's lined with all the big office blocks and buildings i mean if you've been to dallas it's one of your classic american sort of cities where the downtown is slightly been hollowed out of european style
特勤局车后面是载着林登·约翰逊和他的妻子伯德夫人以及参议员亚伯勒的车，然后后面是庞大的随从车队和摩托车，还有载着媒体的媒体车。他们将穿过达拉斯，行驶九英里半到达贸易中心。我认为在这一点上让人们了解路线的关键部分非常重要。他们将穿过达拉斯市中心，沿着主街向南行驶，所以那里排满了所有的大办公楼和建筑。我的意思是，如果你去过达拉斯，它是你典型的美国城市之一，市中心稍微有点像欧洲风格的
shops and it's all banks and businesses and gleaming towers and all of this kind of thing but usually actually deserted in the daytime of course not today yeah ewing oil of course yeah style shops and it's all banks and businesses and gleaming towers and all of this kind of thing but usually actually deserted in the daytime of course not today yeah ewing oil of course yeah they're going to go down main street to the courthouse on deely plaza deely plaza is very small it's like a little triangle of grass at the end of main street they're going to turn right on houston street and then they're going to turn immediately left on elm street which curves down around this little plaza and down into the underpass that will carry them out of the downtown to the trademark so it's very straightforward and on elm street 411 there is a square kind of slightly ugly
商店被掏空了，到处都是银行、企业和闪闪发光的塔楼，所有这些东西，但通常在白天实际上是荒无人烟的，当然今天不是。是的，尤因石油（Ewing Oil），当然。是的，风格商店，到处都是银行、企业和闪闪发光的塔楼，所有这些东西，但通常在白天实际上是荒无人烟的，当然今天不是。是的，尤因石油，当然。他们将沿着主街前往迪利广场（Deely Plaza）的法院。迪利广场非常小，就像主街尽头的一小块三角形草地。他们将右转进入休斯顿街（Houston Street），然后立即左转进入埃尔姆街（Elm Street），这条街绕着这个小广场弯下去，进入地下通道，将他们带出市中心前往贸易中心。所以这非常直接。在埃尔姆街411号，有一座方形的、稍微有点丑的
it looks late 19th century doesn't it but it's kind of collapsed and it's been rebuilt in identical style and this is the texas Depository. But no particular reason why anyone would have any interest in it. No. But just an interesting local feature just off Dealey Plaza. Exactly right. Exactly. It's your classic red brick, six or so storey building, which you would see in every American city. Just a sort of standard warehouse stroke office building. Beyond Daly Plaza, there are three bridges. Is that right? That is the particular focus for security service anxiety. Yeah. They're worried about people
它看起来像19世纪末的，不是吗？但它有点坍塌了，并以相同的风格重建，这就是德克萨斯图书仓库（Texas Depository）。但没有特别的理由让任何人对它感兴趣。没有。但这只是迪利广场外的一个有趣的当地特色。正是如此。正是如此。它是你会在每个美国城市看到的典型的红砖、六层左右的建筑。只是一种标准的仓库兼办公楼。迪利广场外有三座桥。是这样吗？那是安全部门焦虑的特别焦点。是的。他们担心桥上的人。
on the bridges. Exactly right. Exactly right. This is where they're heading towards. Down they go through the suburbs of North Dallas. At 12.06, Kennedy sees some children with placards saying, please stop and shake our hands. So of course he does. This is, again, standard. This is what people do. They'll stop randomly. He gets out, he shakes their hands, lovely, gets back in the car. Isn't there a nun at some point?
正是如此。正是如此。这就是他们前往的地方。他们穿过达拉斯北部的郊区。12点06分，肯尼迪看到一些孩子拿着标语牌，上面写着“请停下来和我们握手”。所以他当然做了。这又是标准的。这就是人们所做的。他们会随机停下来。他下车，和他们握手，很可爱，回到车里。某个地方有个修女吗？
There's a second stop for more children who are standing with the nun. And of course, Kennedy is a good Catholic, loves the idea of stopping for the nun. This kind of thing always makes the Secret Service very jittery, but they just have to put up with it. You know, Kennedy insists upon it.
有第二次停车，是为了更多和修女站在一起的孩子。当然，肯尼迪是一个虔诚的天主教徒，喜欢为修女停车的想法。这种事情总是让特勤局非常紧张，但他们只能忍受。你知道，肯尼迪坚持要这样做。
Now, by now, there have been very large crowds that have assembled in the centre along Main Street and Dealey Plaza. Of course, it's in this point where they are turning to go around this little square that the motorcade will slow and where people will get the best view. And so that's by the Texas School Book Depository and also a grassy section that one might almost describe as a knoll. You might describe it as a knoll. A grassy knoll.
现在，到目前为止，市中心沿着主街和迪利广场已经聚集了非常多的人群。当然，正是在他们转弯绕过这个小广场的地方，车队会减速，人们会得到最好的视野。所以那是在德克萨斯州学校图书仓库旁边，还有一个草地区域，人们几乎可以称之为“草丘”（knoll）。你可能会称之为草丘。草丘。
Tom, maybe at this point I should say. So I visited this spot a couple of months ago and it is much smaller, I think, than you appreciate if you've just seen the footage. It is a very nondescript, perfectly pleasant, but it's a very nondescript point of patch of the city. The grassy knoll, I mean, we would call it a bank. It's just a little bank. It would take you seconds to walk from the top to the bottom, not minutes, but seconds. It is very, very small. You could walk around this area and see everything within five minutes. It is so small. Because the sense that you get often from reading it is that it's enormous
汤姆，也许在这一点上我应该说。所以几个月前我参观了这个地方，我认为它比你如果只看过录像所感受到的要小得多。这是一个非常不起眼、非常令人愉快，但非常不起眼的城市角落。草丘，我的意思是，我们会称之为堤岸。它只是一个小堤岸。你从顶端走到到底部只需要几秒钟，不是几分钟，而是几秒钟。它非常、非常小。你可以在五分钟内走遍这个区域并看到一切。它太小了。因为你从阅读中得到的印象通常是它非常巨大。
and it's full of trees in which people could hide. No, no, not at all. Not at all. So I think that's very important to make that clear. Even the road, it's not especially wide. I mean, there's multi-lanelane but you can stroll across within seconds this is a small patch of dallas now the crowds have already assembled and at 12 15 a man called arnold roland says to his wife so that's in dealey plaza yes he says to his wife hey would you like to see a secret service man because of course people are conscious the secret service is going to be there yeah and he indicates a man that he sees, he says, with a rifle on the sixth floor of the Texas Book Depository. And they watch this bloke for a little while and think, gosh, a Secret Service man.
而且那里树木丛生，人们可以躲在里面。不，不，完全不是这样。完全不是。所以我认为明确这一点非常重要。即使是那条路，也不是特别宽。我的意思是，虽然有多条车道，但你几秒钟内就能走过去。这就是达拉斯的一小块区域，现在人群已经聚集起来了。12点15分，一个叫阿诺德·罗兰的人对他的妻子说——那是迪利广场——是的，他对妻子说，嘿，你想见见特勤局的人吗？因为人们当然知道特勤局的人会在那里。是的，他指着他看到的一个人，他说，那个人在德克萨斯州教科书仓库大楼的六楼拿着步枪。他们盯着这个家伙看了一会儿，心想，天哪，真是个特勤局的人。
I just mentioned that in passing. We'll come back to other sightings. By 1222, the motorcade has reached Main Street in downtown Dallas. The Kennedy's staff are delighted. The crowds are very thick, very warm. They're much more enthusiastic than the Kennedy people had feared. Kennedy's staff are pleased to see that both he and particularly Jackie, because they're always anxious about Jackie,
我只是顺便提一下。我们稍后再谈其他目击事件。到12点22分，车队已经到达达拉斯市中心的干道。肯尼迪的工作人员很高兴。人群非常密集，非常热情。他们比肯尼迪团队担心的要热情得多。肯尼迪的工作人员很高兴看到他和杰奎琳，尤其是杰奎琳，因为他们总是为杰奎琳感到焦虑，
because of course she is not a politician. And she's been through this terrible trauma of losing her child. She's lost the child, but also she's a naturally quite shy person. So she's been advised to look away from her husband, hasn't she? So that people on both sides of the motorcade will have a look at one of the couple. Yeah, so that everybody will leave happy. Everyone will have seen the face of one of the couple. Exactly right.
因为她当然不是政客。她刚刚经历了失去孩子的可怕创伤。她失去了孩子，而且她天生就是一个相当害羞的人。所以有人建议她不要看她的丈夫，对吧？这样车队两侧的人都能看到这对夫妇中的一人。是的，这样每个人都会满意地离开。每个人都能看到这对夫妇中一人的脸。完全正确。
Dallas police, by the way, at this point this point 12 22 are already quite jumpy because the crowds are so much bigger than they had anticipated and they are sort of radioing back and forth saying we need more people we need you know everybody on high alert all of this kind of thing we'll come back to this multiple times i'm sure in this discussion the idea that dallas police are kind of inept amateur amateurish, disengaged, all of these kinds of things is not right at all. They are very on edge. At about 12.25, another bystander, a chap called Howard Brennan, he looks up at the book depository building above Dealey Plaza, and he notices that there are three men on the fifth floor looking out of the window
顺便说一句，达拉斯警方在12点22分这个时间点已经相当紧张了，因为人群比他们预期的要大得多。他们正在来回用无线电说，我们需要更多的人，我们需要每个人都处于高度戒备状态，诸如此类。我相信在这次讨论中我们会多次回到这一点，即认为达拉斯警方无能、业余、不负责任等等，这种想法完全是不对的。他们非常紧张。大约12点25分，另一位旁观者，一个叫霍华德·布伦南的家伙，他抬头看向迪利广场上方的教科书仓库大楼，他注意到有三个人在五楼往窗外看，
or sort of lurking by the window. There are three African-American men who are staff of the book depository. He doesn't know that. And he sees that they're above them on the sixth floor. There is a man who appears to be sitting on the windowsill looking out. Two other men at about the same time who work at the nearby Dallas auditor's office. So they are called Ronald Fisher and Bob Edwards. They also see a man in the sixth floor window. They describe him as looking away from the motorcade and looking towards the under bus. So this is what, 1228, the motorcade is approaching Dealey Plaza. And so obviously, as the president comes, I mean, if you've assembled to see the
或者说是潜伏在窗边。那是三名非裔美国人，他们是教科书仓库的员工。他不知道这一点。他看到他们在他们上方的六楼。有一个人似乎坐在窗台上向外看。大约在同一时间，另外两个在附近达拉斯审计办公室工作的人，他们叫罗纳德·费舍尔和鲍勃·爱德华兹。他们也看到了六楼窗户里的一个人。他们描述他没有看车队，而是看向立交桥方向。所以这是12点28分，车队正在接近迪利广场。显然，当总统到来时，我的意思是，如果你聚集在这里是为了看
president, you're going to turn and look at the motorcade. So the fact that this guy is not- Is peculiar. Is peculiar. And worth noting. And that's why they notice. Otherwise they wouldn wouldn't notice they wouldn't think about it yeah 12 29 kennedy has probably a minute and a half to live 12 29 the motorcade reaches the end of main street the very first police motorbikes are beginning to turn right onto houston street and then they will turn left onto elm street immediately the crowds here are very thick and the motorcade is now moving very slowly. And is that because Kennedy wants to make sure that they see him?
总统，你肯定会转过身去看车队。所以这家伙没有看——这很奇怪。这很奇怪。值得注意。这就是他们注意到的原因。否则他们不会注意到，也不会去想它。是的，12点29分，肯尼迪可能还有一分半钟的生命。12点29分，车队到达干道的尽头。第一批警用摩托车开始右转进入休斯顿街，然后他们会立即左转进入埃尔姆街。这里的人群非常密集，车队现在移动得非常缓慢。这是因为肯尼迪想确保他们能看到他吗？
Yes. It's a response to the enthusiasm. It's not because they're kind of starting to crowd the car or anything. No, no. I think it's sort of inherent in any motorcade that the greater the crowds, the slower you will go. The driver becomes more cautious, but also you want to milk the moment. So they approach the plaza.
是的。这是对热情的反应。并不是因为他们开始挤向汽车什么的。不，不。我认为任何车队都有一种内在的规律，人群越多，你走得就越慢。司机变得更加谨慎，但你也想充分利用这一刻。所以他们接近广场。
So literally the last minute of Kennedy's life, he is buoyed by the love and enthusiasm of the crowds who come to meet him. Absolutely right. And it's at this point that Nellie Connolly leans back to Kennedy and says to him, Mr. President, they can't make you believe now that there aren't people in Dallas who love and appreciate you, can they? And Kennedy kind of grins and he says, no, they can't. So in other words, at this point, the trip could hardly have gone better. They are
所以肯尼迪生命的最后时刻，他被前来迎接他的人群的爱和热情所鼓舞。完全正确。就在这时，内莉·康纳利向后靠向肯尼迪，对他说，总统先生，现在你不能再说达拉斯没有人爱戴和欣赏你了吧？肯尼迪笑了笑说，不，他们不能。换句话说，在这一点上，这次旅行几乎不能更完美了。他们
delighted. So that's the last thing that he says, agreeing that he's loved by the people of Dallas. I think that's right. Yeah. You're very keen on this irony, Tom, I can tell. Well, I mean, it's not the great modern tragedy for nothing. No. So this point, 12.29, the police chief signals to the dispatcher at headquarters. He says, we are now approaching the underpass. And 15 seconds before 12.30, Kennedy's car makes the turn. It's turned right at the end of Main Street.
很高兴。所以这是他说的最后一句话，同意他受到达拉斯人民的爱戴。我想那是对的。是的。汤姆，我看得出来你很喜欢这种讽刺。嗯，我的意思是，它之所以成为伟大的现代悲剧是有原因的。不。所以这一点，12点29分，警察局长向总部的调度员发出信号。他说，我们现在正在接近立交桥。在12点30分前15秒，肯尼迪的车转弯了。它在干道尽头右转。
It now makes the turn left into Elm Street. So we'll go along the side of Deedee Plaza and within seconds they will be in the underpass. And it's at 12.30 exactly that the first shot rings around the square. Now, most people at that point think, a firecracker? What is it? They are stunned. Some people haven't even heard it. Some people have heard it and think it's a firework. Or a car backfiring or something.
它现在左转进入埃尔姆街。所以我们将沿着迪利广场的侧面行驶，几秒钟内他们就会进入立交桥。就在12点30分整，第一声枪响在广场上回荡。现在，大多数人在那一刻想，是鞭炮吗？那是什么？他们惊呆了。有些人甚至没听到。有些人听到了，以为是烟花。或者是汽车回火之类的。
Yeah. Several people immediately think it's a rifle shot. So Governor Connolly is one of them. He is a very keen hunter. He recognizes it as a rifle shot, and he shouts out, oh, no. At the sound of the shot, we know from the footage being taken by another bystander abraham sapruder on a kind of handheld film camera we know that both jackie kennedy and nelly connolly turn their heads to the right so that's towards the side of the square
是的。几个人立即认为那是步枪射击。所以康纳利州长就是其中之一。他是一个非常热衷的猎人。他认出那是步枪射击，他大喊，哦，不。在枪声响起时，我们从另一位旁观者亚伯拉罕·扎普鲁德用手持摄像机拍摄的镜头中知道，杰奎琳·肯尼迪和内莉·康纳利都把头转向了右边，也就是广场那一侧，
that contains the book depository and of course the grassy knoll the slope multiple witnesses so for example a homeless man called james warrell a teenager called amos ewins a steam fitter called howard brennan who i've already mentioned testified that at this point they look up and they see a man at the window of the texas book depository with something that looks like a pipe or conceivably a rifle poking out of the window that their instinct was to look up and see it. But of course, as the sound of the firecracker echoes around the plaza with so many people, with so many cars and motorbikes, most people are confused initially about where the sound has come from.
那里有教科书仓库，当然还有格拉西诺尔（草丘）。多名目击者，例如一个叫詹姆斯·沃雷尔的无家可归者，一个叫阿莫斯·尤因斯的少年，一个叫霍华德·布伦南的蒸汽管道工（我已经提到过他），作证说在这一点上他们抬头看，看到德克萨斯州教科书仓库的窗户里有一个人，窗户里伸出一个看起来像管子或可能是步枪的东西。他们的本能是抬头看。但是，当然，当鞭炮声在广场上回荡时，由于有这么多人、这么多汽车和摩托车，大多数人最初对声音的来源感到困惑。
But Dominic, just at this point to say that if it had been recognised that it was a rifle shot, and Connolly presumably does, so I'm wondering you know does he duck i can't remember i haven't looked at the zapruder film even if kennedy knew what it was he can't duck can he because he has this corset on yeah and so he is kind of frozen rigidly he's much much less mobile than anyone else he is he is you're right he's absolutely less mobile than anybody else but so little time goes by tom it's. I mean, I've never been in a motorcade, but you can easily imagine that there was a kind of sensory overload, thousands of people
但是多米尼克，就在这一点上，如果当时被认出是步枪射击，康纳利大概认出来了，所以我很好奇，他躲避了吗？我不记得了，我没看过扎普鲁德的电影。即使肯尼迪知道那是什么，他也躲不开，对吧？因为他穿着紧身胸衣。是的，所以他僵硬地冻住了，他比任何人都更难移动。他是，你是对的，他确实比任何人都更难移动。但是时间过得太快了，汤姆。我的意思是，我从来没有参加过车队，但你可以很容易地想象有一种感官过载，成千上万的人
screaming, the noise of the engines, the flags flying, the sense of excitement. And also disbelief, disbelief that it's happening because Connolly kind of, he says, oh no, doesn't he? Like he knows what's happening, but there isn't enough time to deal with the horror that he suddenly is faced with. And there must be the kind of everyone hoping that it is just a car backfiring or a firecracker. Well, it could easily be a car backfiring, right? I mean, it absolutely could easily be that.
尖叫，引擎的噪音，飘扬的旗帜，兴奋的感觉。还有难以置信，难以置信正在发生的事情，因为康纳利说，哦，不，不是吗？就像他知道发生了什么，但没有足够的时间来处理他突然面临的恐怖。而且一定有每个人都希望那只是汽车回火或鞭炮。嗯，那很容易是汽车回火，对吧？我的意思是，那绝对很容易是那样。
Yeah. It is seven seconds then till the second shot rings out. And we can tell exactly what happens from the Zapruder film footage that so many people have seen elements of this in Oliver Stone's film JFK. And Dominic, just to emphasize how weird it is that this is shot, because of course, you know, this is long before iPhones or it's hard to shoot video footage if you're just a kind of normal citizen. And the fact that we have this video
是的。然后是七秒钟，直到第二声枪响。我们可以从扎普鲁德的电影镜头中准确地看出发生了什么，很多人在奥利弗·斯通的电影《刺杀肯尼迪》中看过其中的片段。多米尼克，强调一下这被拍摄下来是多么奇怪，因为当然，你知道，这远在iPhone出现之前，如果你只是一个普通公民，很难拍摄视频。而我们有这个视频
footage, it's about 25 seconds, isn't it? I mean, it's amazing. Now, as we get into this discussion, the version of events that we will be giving you is the version that is pretty much endorsed by the Warren Commission as it were the official version. So those listeners who are more sceptical of the official version will want to take what follows with a pinch of salt, I suppose. But according to the official version, and according to, for example, Vincent Berglieri's book, it's at this point at 12 30 in seven seconds the second shot rings out kennedy as you can tell from the zapruder footage appears to be hit somewhere in the region of his right shoulder we see his elbows fly up in the footage in a very weird kind of you know it's not the sort of hollywood impact scene you'd expect his his arms kind of
片段，大约25秒，不是吗？我的意思是，这太神奇了。现在，当我们进入这个讨论时，我们将给出的事件版本是沃伦委员会基本认可的版本，也就是官方版本。所以那些对官方版本更怀疑的听众，我想会想对接下来发生的事情持保留态度。但根据官方版本，例如根据文森特·布格里奥西的书，就在12点30分7秒，第二声枪响，肯尼迪正如你可以从扎普鲁德的镜头中看出的那样，似乎在右肩区域被击中。我们在镜头中看到他的肘部飞起，以一种非常奇怪的方式，你知道，这不是你期望的那种好莱坞冲击场景，他的手臂，
go up and his elbows fly up he's clear distress you can see this in his face but of course tom as you've said the corset keeps him upright the back brace means that he does not slump and he's on this elevated seat yeah a millisecond or so after this john John Connolly, who is in sees this and takes him into her arms. And with this second shot, immediately the Secret Service know that this is not a firecracker. This is not a car backfiring. And it's at this point that Rufus Youngblood, LBJ's Secret Service man, throws LBJ onto the floor of his car and throws himself on top of him. The training kicks in. But this is all compressed in such little time because just a second and a half later, at 12.30 and eight and a half seconds,
向上抬起，肘部飞起。他显然很痛苦，你可以在他的脸上看到这一点。但当然，汤姆，正如你所说，紧身胸衣让他保持直立，背部支架意味着他没有瘫倒，而且他坐在那个升高的座位上。是的，在那之后大约一毫秒，约翰·康纳利看到了这一点，并把他抱在怀里。随着这第二声枪响，特勤局立即知道这不是鞭炮。这不是汽车回火。就在这时，鲁弗斯·扬布拉德，LBJ（林登·约翰逊）的特勤局人员，把LBJ扔到车底，并扑在他身上。训练发挥了作用。但这所有的一切都压缩在如此短的时间内，因为仅仅一秒半后，在12点30分8.5秒，
there is a third shot. And this is the shot that hits Kennedy on the right-hand side of his head. His body at this point topples into Jackie. Part of his skull has been shot off. She is screaming, they have shot my husband. They clearly reflecting the existing fears that they had about their reception in Dallas. Part of his head has fallen into her hand or she has caught it or whatever. The front of the car, Bill Greer, the driver starts to accelerate away. He already knows what
有第三声枪响。这就是击中肯尼迪头部右侧的那一枪。他的身体在这一点上倒向杰奎琳。他的一部分头骨被击碎了。她在尖叫，他们射杀了我的丈夫。他们显然反映了他们对在达拉斯受到接待的现有恐惧。他头的一部分掉进了她的手里，或者她抓住了它，或者其他什么。车前部，司机比尔·格里尔开始加速离开。他已经知道发生了什么
has happened. Secret servicemen have jumped down from the cars behind and are running towards the the front of the car bill greer the driver starts to accelerate away he already knows what has happened secret servicemen have jumped down from the cars behind and are running towards the car one of them clint hill climbs onto the back of the car just a moment later jackie kennedy in her pink suit in the scene that everybody will have seen so many times she actually starts to almost get out of the car and climb backwards. Why she's doing that has always... Well, she's interviewed about that. She says she doesn't know. She has no recollection of it.
了。特勤人员从后面的车上跳下来，正跑向车前部。司机比尔·格里尔开始加速离开，他已经知道发生了什么。特勤人员从后面的车上跳下来，正跑向车子。其中一个叫克林特·希尔的人爬上了车后部。片刻之后，穿着粉红色套装的杰奎琳·肯尼迪，在每个人都看过无数次的场景中，她实际上开始几乎要爬出车外，向后爬。她为什么要那样做一直……嗯，她接受过关于那件事的采访。她说她不知道。她对此没有任何记忆。
Yeah. It's as though she's looking at a totally different person. Exactly. I mean, Tom, 10 seconds ago, all was well. Of course. And they were making the turn. 10 seconds later, three shots have rung out and they're in total chaos and panic. Shock doesn't even begin to describe what she is going
是的。就好像她在看着一个完全不同的人。完全正确。我的意思是，汤姆，10秒前，一切都很好。当然。他们正在转弯。10秒后，三声枪响，他们陷入了彻底的混乱和恐慌。震惊甚至不足以描述她正在经历的事情，
through, but it is possible, some experts think, in her confusion, part of her husband's head has been shot away. And she's reaching for it. And she's trying to get it. She's trying to, yeah, pick up the missing bits of JFK's head. That would be your instinct, right? Right. If something happened to your family member, that would be your instinct. And the horror of it is, from this point on, she is cradling her husband's head in her arms and kind of holding it together with the feeling that if she doesn't, the skull will just disintegrate. Exactly right. Exactly. At this very moment, Howard Brennan, who's been watching the whole time, sees what he thinks is a man withdrawing a gun from the sixth floor window.
但一些专家认为，在她的困惑中，她丈夫头的一部分被击碎了。她在伸手去拿它。她在试图，是的，捡起JFK头部缺失的部分。那会是你的本能，对吧？对。如果你的家人发生了什么事，那会是你的本能。而恐怖之处在于，从这一点开始，她一直把丈夫的头抱在怀里，并试图把它固定住，感觉如果她不这样做，头骨就会散架。完全正确。完全正确。就在这一刻，一直盯着看的霍华德·布伦南看到他认为是一个人从六楼窗户撤回一把枪。
At the same moment, a press photographer called Bob Jackson, who is in the motorcade behind Kennedy, he says that he also sees a man withdrawing something from the sixth floor window of the Texas Book Depository. He actually shouts to his colleagues about it. And a TV cameraman called Malcolm Couch looks up and he says that he also sees the same thing. Now, of course, there are lots of different eyewitness reports about what went on at Dealey Plaza. I'm not saying these are the only eyewitnesses, but it is important to say that right from the beginning, there were people who said they had seen a gunman at the sixth floor window with a weapon. We're now nine seconds past 12.30 and the car is accelerating now into the underpass.
同一时刻，一位叫鲍勃·杰克逊的摄影记者，他在肯尼迪后面的车队里，他说他也看到一个人从德克萨斯州教科书仓库的六楼窗户撤回了什么东西。他甚至对同事大喊大叫。一位叫马尔科姆·库奇的电视摄影师抬头看，他说他也看到了同样的事情。当然，关于迪利广场发生了什么，有很多不同的目击者报告。我并不是说这些是唯一的目击者，但必须说，从一开始，就有很多人说他们看到六楼窗户里有一个拿着武器的枪手。现在是12点30分9秒，车子正在加速进入立交桥。
There is blood all over the back seat. Nellie Connolly and her husband, John Connolly, are kind of huddled down in the jump seats. All the radios are full of discord and screaming. And they're saying, get to Parkland Memorial Hospital. Parkland Memorial Hospital is about four miles from Dealey Plaza. It's the best hospital in the city. So by 12.31, they're out of the underpass and they're heading along the freeway, rushing towards Parkland Memorial Hospital. hospital as you say tom jackie is cradling her husband's body and she's crying and saying jack jack i love you and all this kind of thing so upsetting and just before we
后座上全是血。内莉·康纳利和她的丈夫约翰·康纳利蜷缩在跳板座位上。所有的无线电里都充满了不和谐的声音和尖叫。他们说，去帕克兰纪念医院。帕克兰纪念医院距离迪利广场大约四英里。它是城里最好的医院。所以到12点31分，他们已经出了立交桥，正沿着高速公路疾驰，冲向帕克兰纪念医院。正如你所说，汤姆，杰奎琳抱着她丈夫的身体，她在哭，说杰克，杰克，我爱你，诸如此类。太令人心碎了。就在我们
end this episode it's at about this point 12 31 that with policemen now running around deely plaza in a complete and utter panic the the crowds are in panic, just utter chaos. One police motorbike officer runs into the book depository. This is a man called Marion Baker. And he sees the superintendent of the book depository, a chap called Roy Truly. And they go upstairs. And on the second floor, they bump into a man. And the policeman pulls a gun on him.
结束这一集之前，大约在12点31分，随着警察现在在迪利广场完全恐慌地跑来跑去，人群陷入了恐慌，简直是一片混乱。一名摩托车警察跑进教科书仓库。这是一个叫马里昂·贝克的人。他看到了教科书仓库的负责人，一个叫罗伊·特鲁利的人。他们上楼了。在二楼，他们撞见了一个人。警察对他拔出了枪。
And the man looks utterly expressionless. He doesn't react in any way. He just seems almost in a daze. And Roy truly says, it's fine. I know him. He works here. And they let the man go. He walks past them.
那个人看起来完全面无表情。他没有任何反应。他似乎几乎处于恍惚状态。罗伊·特鲁利说，没关系。我认识他。他在这里工作。他们放走了那个人。他从他们身边走过。
He passed another supervisor. That man, Tom, is Lee Harvey Os oswald i think at that point we should have a pause in our narrative of this terrible day and when we come back we will go through the aftermath of the shooting of drama and trauma and days that have generated decades and decades worth of talk of conspiracy theories. So we will see you next time. But of course, Tom, if people are members of the Rest Is History Club, they can listen to all those episodes right away. And if you're not a member of the Rest Is History Club, you can sign up and get all those episodes right now at therestishistory.com.
他经过了另一位主管。那个人，汤姆，就是李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德。我想在这一点上，我们应该暂停一下对这一可怕日子的叙述。当我们回来时，我们将经历枪击后的余波、戏剧和创伤，以及那些引发了数十年阴谋论的日子。所以我们下次见。但当然，汤姆，如果人们是“Rest Is History”俱乐部的成员，他们可以立即收听所有这些剧集。如果你不是“Rest Is History”俱乐部的成员，你可以在therestishistory.com注册并立即获得所有这些剧集。
In any case, we will see you next time for what happens next. Goodbye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip,
无论如何，我们下次见，看看接下来会发生什么。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。